Heute im Rasenfunk? Die Tätigkeit des Portugiesens, mit der rechten Kante, der Schlüssel von Cristiano. Ja Leute, es ist wieder soweit. Die Ligatour ist zurück. Ich freu mich so. Das letzte Format, das noch aus dem Sommerschlaf des Rasenfunks erweckt werden musste. Jetzt sind wir hier mit neuem Intro, denn ihr habt's mitbekommen, der Feed, der heißt jetzt nicht mehr Kurzpass. Kurzpass, was ist das? Das ist nur noch was für Die Hardhörer. Ab jetzt ist das hier die Ligatour. Und da gibt es dann mehrere Formate. Zwei, die regelmäßig erscheinen. Einmal zu den europäischen Top-Ligen und einmal zur zweiten in der Bundesliga. Und mal gucken, was sich noch so rein quetschen lässt. Ansonsten, schön, dass ihr da seid. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.com und habe heute drei Gäste bei mir. Zum einen diejenigen, die bei YouTube gucken, die sehen es. Christian Bernhard zu meiner linken. Hallo Christian.
Hallo von den pilligen Platzen.
Du kannst ja näher heran drücken. Also keiner hat dich nach da hinten geschoben. Aber ja, du hast recht. Ein bisschen, ich krieg's anders nicht hin mit der Kamera.
Alles wunderbar.
Schön, dass du hier bist. Dann ist Nils Kern hier. Hallo Nils. Ja, schön, dass du wieder da bist. Und endlich ist er zurück, der verlorene Sohn der Ligatour. Die Älteren kennen ihn noch unter euch. Hendrik Buchheister ist da für die Premier League. Hallo Hendrik. Du musst jetzt erstmal, also du musst dich rechtfertigen. Kannst dann aber auch Werbung machen. Also das ist ein guter Trade-off. Warum warst du denn in der letzten Saison nicht zu hören bei uns?
Ja, vielen Dank für die Plattform. Das nutze ich gern. Ich habe ein Buch geschrieben in der letzten Saison. Handelt von der deutsch-englischen Fußball-Revalität. Heißt We Call It A Classica. Er scheint Anfang November und ist überall erhältlich, wo man Bücher vorbestellen und dann auch kaufen kann.
Sehr, sehr schön. Und damit bist du durchgekommen. Aber das hatte ich ganz schön in Trab gehalten, nehme ich mal an.
Das war in der Tat eine Sache, die mich das letzte Jahr und vor allem das letzte halbe Jahr größtenteils beschäftigt hat. Das stimmt schon.
Da freuen wir uns sehr drauf. Ich denke, wir werden noch das eine oder andere Mal hier über dieses Buch sprechen. Das ist einfach so eine Vermutung meinerseits. Aber jetzt wollen wir nach dem Hinweis, dass der Rasenfunk rein crowdfinanziert ist, auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubkönnt ihr uns unterstützen. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, jetzt wollen wir loslegen. Alle von euch haben zwei Themen mitgebracht. Der kurze Hinweis, die Ligue 1 haben wir diesmal nicht mit dabei. Ein Netzausfall von Vodafone hat uns einen Strich durch die Rechnung gemacht. Vielleicht kann ich das noch als einzelne Folge nachschieben. Heute Nacht mal gucken, das müssen wir spontan entscheiden. Aber jetzt wollen wir erstmal über die drei Ligen sprechen. Und ich würde sagen, Nils, du bist hier einer der Veteranen. Beginn du doch mal. Du hast uns zwei Themen aus der Liga mitgebracht. Wollen wir mit dem Sportlichen vielleicht anfangen?
Mit dem Sportlichen, mit dem schönen Thema.
Läuft bei ihm, bei Real. Das habe sogar ich mitbekommen.
Das hast sogar du in der Sommerpause mitbekommen. Ja, läuft ist ein ganz guter Begriff, der sorgt wirklich für Furore. Und nicht nur das, das ist eigentlich ein schlechter Begriff. Ich meine, der überrascht eigentlich alle in Spanien. Ich meine, hier in der Runde, wir haben öfter schon mal Jude Bellingham spielen sehen, speziell die Bundesliga-Fans. Und das ist klar, da wissen schon mal viele, was der so drauf hat und wie er auch als Typ ist und dass er unbedingt gewinnen will. Also, maximaler Ehrgeiz. Und da hat er jetzt schon einige in Spanien überrascht. Also, die Statistiken sind natürlich schon mal beragt. Er hat jetzt vier Spiele in der Liga gemacht und fünf Tore eine Vorlage überhaupt. Den ersten vier Ligaspielen überhaupt zu treffen, das haben zuletzt Cesc Fabregas und Cristiano Ronaldo geschafft. Also, da ist er schon mal in einer ganz guten Reihe zu nennen. Aber was er da für Real Madrid schon ist, wo es ja auch ein paar aktuellen Ausfälle gibt mit zwei Kreuzbandrissen, Militao, Coutoix und Vinicius auch noch aktuell verletzt und ein paar mehr. Und trotzdem ist Real Madrid mit vier Siegen aus vier Spielen gestartet, dank Bellingham, weil der hier und da einfach immer noch gewinnen will. Und man kann gar nicht genau beschreiben, woran das liegt.
Obwohl er jetzt schon 22 ist oder wie alt ist er?
Manche denken sich dann vielleicht doch mal in der 90. Minute, ah heute wird das nichts, aber wie der noch brennt, das war jetzt auch bei diesem späten 2 zu 1 gegen Krita für 95. Minute. Da gab es dann noch den –Lucas Vazquez hat geschossen und bevor der überhaupt ausgeholt hat, ist schon Bellingham in den Strafraum gestartet, weil er einfach brennt und lauert und meint, vielleicht kommt der doch noch bei mir. Ja, Torwart hat den Ball nicht gefangen können, lässt vor sich abprallen und dann ist auf einmal Bellingham schon da. Also, ja, überrascht da viele mit dieser Siegermentalität, mit immer brennen und da sein und auch, wie er sich schon ein bisschen mit Gegenspielern anlegt. Man weiß ja auch, dass er hier und da ein bisschen ein ekliger Gegenspieler sein kann. Also da, wie gesagt, sorgt er für Furore, aber auch für großes Überraschen in Spanien, wie gut der wirklich ist. Ich meine, der hat ja trotzdem über 100 Millionen gekostet. Und trotzdem denken sich die Leute, wow, wo kommt der denn her? Ja, Leute, mehr Bundesliga gucken oder mehr Rasenfunk hören in Spanien.
Genau, genau. Wann kommt das spanische Outlet? Das musst dann du machen. Hendrik, ich nehme mal an, in England ist man nicht so ganz überrascht von der Leistung von Bellingham. Aber ich habe jetzt mitbekommen, Nations League gegen Schottland, das scheint auch wieder so eine kleine Bellingham-Galashow gewesen zu sein, zumindest in Ansätzen. Wird das auch wahrgenommen in England?
Das war eine Bellingham-Gala, das kann man schon so sagen. Genau, das war jetzt ein Freundschaftsspiel gegen Schottland, wobei Freundschaftsspiel gegen Schottland, das muss man ja auch in Anführungszeichen setzen, weil England und Schottland ja immer eine große Geschichte ist. Da war Bellingham in der Tat…
Da müsste man mal ein Buch drüber schreiben, über die Rebellität.
Ja, das muss man mal gucken, ob sie das in Deutschland verkauft. Und da war tatsächlich aber Jude Bellingham auch der überragende Mann, der war an allen Toren beteiligt, eins direkt aufgelegt, eins geschossen. Er hat auch in dieser etwas vorgezogenen 10er-Position gespielt, die er auch bei Real und Angelotti spielt. England hat immer das Problem gehabt, wie man das Mittelfeld richtig ausbalanciert, zwischen defensiven und offensiven Optionen. Und da ist Bellingham als 10er und dahinter zwei defensivere Leute. Das ist jetzt eine echt gute Variante gewesen. Und er ist tatsächlich auch der Grund, warum viele Leute in England schon wieder sagen, dass bei der EM im kommenden Jahr in Deutschland England jetzt aber dringend den Titel holen muss. Und man muss aber auch sagen, so ein Talent wie Bellingham hat man hier einfach lange nicht gehabt. Und wir in diesem Alter –ihr habt es auch schon angesprochen –in der Nationalmannschaft dominieren bei einem Verein wie Real Madrid. Das ist schon extrem beachtlich und das wird auch hier wahrgenommen.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde es auch extrem beeindruckend. Ich meine, den sportlichen Wert, den kannte man vielleicht oder konnte man sich ahnen. Aber dass Real Madrid das ja für Siegermentalität, für Erfolg steht, dass dann so ein junger Spieler da neu hinkommt, in neues Land, neue Sprache und gleich von Anfang an nochmal diese Winnermentalität anscheinend auf ein anderes Niveau hält, das ist schon beeindruckend.
Ja, auch unter seinen Mitspielern, die können sich auch kaum erklären, wie das kommt. Also es wird immer hervorgehoben, so von Toni Kroos, David Alaba gab es jetzt Aussagen, dass er eben keinen Halligalli macht, dass er keinen Harakiri macht, dass er da sehr klar in seinen Aktionen ist. Und trotzdem, wie er da das Team schon mitreißt und anfeuert und irgendwie auch diese Ausstrahlung hat, so hey, ich bin hier, ich will jetzt hier was reißen, dann eben auch auf mehr oder weniger ungewohnter Position. Diese 10. Position ist es nominell in der Aufstellung, aber er steht teilweise noch vor der Doppelspitze, weil er einfach diese Anspielstation im Strafraum auch darstellt, was Real Madrid die letzten Jahre hier und da vielleicht auch gefehlt hat, weil Benzmeier eher außerhalb des Strafraums stattgefunden hat. Er bringt da so viel und Torgefahr, was man vielleicht in der Bundesliga noch gar nicht so gesehen hat, dass er auch wirklich ganz da vorne Zielspieler sein kann, aber er ist überall auf dem Platz und irgendwie der ganze Madridismo liegt ihm jetzt schon zu Füßen. Logisch, wenn du irgendwie in der 95. Minute im Bernabeu, was als er das erste Heimspiel der Saison war, nach langer Zeit, da das Siegtor erzielst, so auf die Art und Weise dann mit frisch 20 Jahren geworden, sind da gleich die Superlative, gehen natürlich ins Unermessliche.
Krass, habe ich ihn ja vorhin schon zwei Jahre zu alt gemacht mit meinen 22. Aber sag noch ganz kurz, Nils, also Real hat jetzt auch ein bisschen seine Formation verändert. Also 4-4-2 mit Raute, aber wenn Bellingham auch in die Spitze geht, ist es dann wieder ein 4-3-3.
Kann man so sagen. Ja, jetzt gibt es eine klarere Aufteilung im Mittelfeld mit einem klareren Sechser. In dem Fall Aurelia und Xho Ameni, dann eben diese zwei auf den Außen. Mal Valverde, Kammer, Wingen, mal Kroster zwischen Modric und dann eben Bellingham nominell auf der 10. Und dann eben mehr eine Doppelspitze als jetzt früher waren. So wie in den letzten Jahren waren es immer klare Flügelspieler. Deswegen ist das für Vinicius aktuell nicht so optimal. Der wird eher schon 20 Meter vorm Strafraum mitrücken zum Strafraum angespielt. Da tut er sich noch schwer. Der braucht halt eher schon an der Mittellinie angespielt werden und dann 50 Meter Vollgas. Also es ist noch nicht hundertprozentig das System, weil Vinicius sich nicht so richtig wohlfühlt. Aber Rodrigo ist näher am Strafraum. Bellingham kann machen, was er will. Er hat da viele Freiheiten. Deswegen geht dieses 4-1-2-1-2 aktuell auf, weil Real da auch Probleme hatte, im Strafraum Kontakte zu haben. Und da hast du einfach jetzt schon mal einen Mann mehr in der Nähe des Strafraums. Deswegen kommen da aktuell diese vier Siege aus vier Spielen so zusammen.
Und so führt Real die Tabelle an vor Girona und Barca, dann kommen Atletico und Athletic Bilbao. Auf andere Teams werden wir natürlich in den nächsten Wochen blicken. Ab jetzt kommt die europäische Ligatour wieder alle zwei Wochen. Also nicht durchdrehen, liebe Liga-Freunde da draußen. Es gibt ja auch den Tiki-Taka-Fußball-Podcast. Da geht es ja noch viel, viel, viel näher ins Detail. Aber wenn wir jetzt schon bei Teams sind, die ihre Mittelfeldstruktur verändern, ich glaube, Hendrik, wir haben eine goldene Brücke zu Liverpool, über die wir sprechen könnten, die allerdings jetzt in der Liga nach vier Spielen nicht ganz so gut wie real dastehen, aber doch sehr gut. Zehn Punkte, drei Siege, ein Unentschieden. Nur City ist das Team, das bisher alle Spiele gewinnen konnte. Und bei Liverpool hat sich ja auch einiges im Mittelfeld verändert.
Da hat sich in der Tat einiges verändert oder kann man auch sagen alles verändert. Also die mussten in der Saison eigentlich ein komplett neues Mittelfeld bauen. Es war ja schon länger klar, dass dann Umbruch her musste. Der war auch eingeleitet worden, dass man Mabikeyta abgegeben hat, dass man Alex Sub-State-Chamberlain abgegeben hat, dass man James Milner abgegeben hat. Und dann kamen im Sommer noch etwas unvermittelt diese Angebote aus Saudi-Arabien dazu für John Henderson und Fabinho, die dann beide auch noch mit dem Verein verlassen haben. Und damit war nicht unbedingt zu rechnen. Und dadurch war dann der Klub unter Druck, tatsächlich im Sommer ein komplett neues Mittelfeld zu bauen. Also dieser lange angepeilte Umbruch ist dann deutlich radikaler ausgefallen, als es geplant war. Und hat man mitbekommen in Deutschland, dass es nicht so ganz einfach gelaufen ist, da Ersatz zu beschaffen. Also Moises Casedo hatte man ja praktisch schon sicher. Er hat sich dann doch für Chelsea entschieden. Und jetzt hat Liverpool aber in der Tat doch ein komplett neues Mittelfeld. Und das macht sich so nach den ersten vier Spielen wirklich gut. Also Endo, der jetzt zuletzt dazugekommen ist, da waren die Fans so ein bisschen underwhelmed zum Start, als der dann bekannt gegeben wurde, statt Casedo, was glaube ich aber auch so ein bisschen dran liegt, dass er in der Bundesliga so ein bisschen unter dem Radar lief, für englische Beobachter, hat sich gut eingefunden. Dann Alexis Necaylister, argentinischer Weltmeister, den man von der WM noch kennt, vom Kampf von Brighton. Und vor allem aber Dominic de Boschloy aus Leipzig. Und der hat einen extrem guten Start erwischt, hat auch schon getroffen. Und ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen der neue Liebling von Anfield geworden, in diesen ersten vier Spielen. Ja, bei Liverpool war nach der schwachen letzten Saison, mit Pasta Champions die Quali auch so ein bisschen unklar, was wird in der neuen Saison. Und ist das vielleicht so ein bisschen die Saison, in der Klopp seine Magie dann endgültig verliert. Aber es sieht so ein bisschen aus, als würde das genaue Gegenteil eintreten, dass er es mal wieder schafft, diesen Verein, also eine neue Inkarnation dieses Klopp-Liverpools hinzubekommen. Und wie gesagt, der Saisonstart war überraschend gut. Vor allem das Spiel gegen Newcastle muss man rausstreichen, wo sie in Unterzahl waren, zurücklagen und das Spiel dann trotzdem noch gedreht haben durch zwei Tore von Darwin. Spieler, die lange verletzt waren, sind zurück, Luis Dias und Jogo Jota. Und nach den ersten vier Spielen sieht es so aus, als könnte Liverpool tatsächlich eine gute Rolle spielen, also Meisterschaft nicht, weil da muss man auch ehrlicherweise sagen, dass es wahrscheinlich wieder Manchester City werden. Aber dahinter, die Champions-League-Plätze sind ja Up for grabs und ich glaube, da hat Liverpool eine gute Chance mitzuspielen. Was man in den ersten Spielen schon auch sehen kann, es wird ein extrem unterhaltsames Liverpool, weil vorne haben sie natürlich eine Offensivpower, die so international kaum jemand mithalten kann. Aber die Abwehr hat halt doch deutliche Schwächen, sowohl in der Tiefe als auch individuell. Trent Alexander-Arnold ist auf seiner rechten Außenverteidiger-Position, wo er dann so ein bisschen reinschiebt. Das ist ein Unsicherheitsfaktor, das hat man schon mehrmals gesehen. Konaté war jetzt auch verletzt von Dyke viel aus, also da wird es dann schon dünn. Liverpool wird viele Tore kassieren und die werden auch viele schießen. Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an dieses Liverpool-Saison, ich glaube 2017, 2018, also die erste Saison unter Klopp, wo sie dann auch erstmals in die Champions-League angezogen sind. Das war ja auch extrem spektakulär in jeder Hinsicht. Das war nicht immer solide defensiv, aber extrem spektakulär. Und so könnte die Saison auch wieder laufen.
Das ist schon echt erstaunlich. Aber spielt denn Liverpool auch anders? Allein von der Formation hat sich im Vergleich zu real nicht so viel verändert.
Genau, das ist nach wie vor die gleiche Formation. Es hat sich natürlich die Balance im Mittelfeld so ein bisschen verändert. Also vorher war es schon mit Henderson und Fabinho, die ja schon eher defensiv und auf Sicherheit gedacht haben, natürlich schon ein bisschen defensiver angelegt. Das Mittelfeld war vor allem dazu da, um Bälle zurückzugewinnen. Jetzt hat man mit Savoslai und auch McAllister so ein bisschen eine offensivere Ausrichtung. Aber im Grunde ist das immer noch das typische Liverpool, was man aus den letzten Jahren kennt.
Das ist schon erstaunlich. Da schafft man es einfach so, das komplette Mittelfeld auszutauschen. Das will ich mal bei Bayern sehen.
Ich finde, Hendrik hatte schon viele genannt, ich finde, dass zum Beispiel gerade McAllister so ein krasser Stil war. Also auch was der preislich, wenn man sich die Premier League Preise anschaut, also was der Ablöse gekostet hat. Und McAllister ist so einer, der fällt vielleicht nicht immer, er ist nicht der Highlight-Spieler, aber wir wissen alle, welche wichtige Rolle er bei den Argentinern hatte, was auch bei Brighton unter der Zerbe mitgenommen hat. Und ich glaube, den Transfer schon so früh da einbauen zu können, glaube ich, hat Klopp unter Mannschaft sehr gut getan.
Ja, total. Und was natürlich so ein bisschen so ein Stilbuch ist von Klopp, also in der Vergangenheit war es ja oft so, dass Transfers so ein bisschen eine Anlaufphase brauchten und dass er sie so behutsam eingebaut hat, das kann er sich natürlich jetzt nicht leisten. Also gerade die Leute im Mittelfeld, die müssen tatsächlich von, die müssen ab sofort performen und das klappt wirklich erstaunlich gut. Dazu muss man natürlich sagen, Mohamed Salah konnten sie halten, das war ja noch so ein bisschen das große Thema der letzten Tage der Transferphase, ob er noch nach Saudi-Arabien wechselt, den haben sie halten können. Und der ist natürlich nach wie vor nicht zu ersetzen, das muss man einfach sagen. Und ist ja auch immer noch so, wenn man so an die erste Inkarnation des Klopp, Liverpool zurückdenkt, so der Schlüsselspieler von damals, das ist ja auch nach wie vor noch, aber drumherum ist es dann schon erstaunlich, wie sich dieser Verein in den letzten Jahren und vor allem in diesem Sommer auch nochmal neu erfunden hat.
Und die Bundesligaspieler, die ausziehen und anderswo richtig, richtig gut performen, das ist schon interessant. Also gerade den Endotransfer, ich hab da mit ein paar Liverpool-Fans geschrieben, ich kenne ja die von The Enfield Rap noch ganz gut, die waren ja auch mal hier im Rasenfunk zu hören. Die haben sich gefreut, aber die haben sich auch in die Daten und in die Szenen reingewühlt, aber die haben ja schon gesagt, ja, es ist gerade ein bisschen schwierig, das hier zu verkaufen, aber wir freuen uns auf den.
Das ist so, weil ja England auch gerade, wenn auf die letzten Tage des Transfer-Fans das zugeht, ja schon ein extremer Fokus drauf liegt, was kosten die und wer hat den, wer holt irgendwie den teuersten Transfer und den meisten Glamour und gerade wenn dann über Kaisedo und über 100 Millionen und so geschrieben wird und dann kommt halt jemand aus der Bundesliga, den man jetzt nicht unbedingt im Schirm hat, ist das natürlich ein bisschen, sind die Leute da erstmal skeptisch, aber ich glaube, da ist er auf einem guten Weg, die Leute auch für sich zu gewinnen.
Aber absolut und weil der Name Dezabu viel, erste Elemente von Dezabu sind in der Bundesliga angekommen. Aufbau auf VfB Stuttgart, mal angucken, wie die Doppel-Sechs da jetzt agiert, das wird jetzt sicher nach der Länderspielpause noch ausformulierter sein, wenn Stille und Karasor das mehr abgesprochen haben, aber es ist wirklich genau dieser Brighton-in-Huff-Aufbau über die Sechser, die so gestaffelt stehen und naja, so verteilt sich das auf die Ligen. Das wäre doch auch mal ein Bundestrainer, aber gut. Der ist leider gerade in Amt und Würden. Jetzt überlege ich gerade, Christian, du hast uns die beiden Mailander-Fahnen mitgebracht, unter anderem wahrscheinlich deshalb, weil sie ungeschlagen gerade die Serie A anführen. Wenn wir jetzt mal beim Thema Mittelfeld umgestalten bleiben, könnten wir doch eigentlich mit Milan beginnen, oder?
Schön, Max, dass du die Brücke nochmal verlängerst. Die bietet sich sehr an. Ja, Milan. Sandro Tonali hat im Sommer den Verein verlassen, Richtung Newcastle, für sehr viel Geld, was auch eine emotionale Geschichte für Milan war, weil er ganz klar der zukünftige Kapitän gewesen wäre. Dazu fällt mit Benazer, der zweite Stammkraft, die Mittelfeld, noch mehrere Monate aus. Also kurz auf den Punkt gebracht, Milan hat über den Sommer sein komplettes Zentrum sozusagen verloren und hat nachgerüstet und hat auch umgestellt. Und man muss sagen, so wie es sich anlässt, sehr gut umgestellt. Also es sind gekommen Loftus Chiek von Chelsea und Reinders von Alkmaar, ein Niederländer. Und Milan hat Piolli, der ja viel mit 4-2-3-1 zuletzt gearbeitet hat, hat jetzt ganz klar auf 4-3-3 umgestellt. Und diese zwei Figuren, Reinders und Loftus Chiek, haben da gleich eine zentrale Rolle, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, weil er eben gesagt hat, ich will mehr Körperlichkeit, ich will mehr Physik, ich will mehr Dynamik. Und sowohl Reinders als auch Loftus Chiek bieten genau das. Viele Tiefenläufe gehen vorne mit rein, sind robust. Reinders, glaube ich, hat jetzt in jedem der ersten drei Spiele mehr als 12,5 Kilometer gelaufen. Ich weiß, viel laufen bedeutet nicht immer automatisch, dass das gut sein muss, aber wenn man sich ihn anschaut, also ich muss sagen, für mich ist er die Überraschung der Saison bisher. Immer Kopf oben, immer präsent, so ein spielmachender Achter, der auch im Spielaufbau eine wichtige Figur hat, aber dann eben auch vorne mit reingeht, Torgefahr ausstrahlt. Und man muss sagen, dieser Switch hat bisher wunderbar funktioniert. Man darf bei Milan vielleicht auch nicht vergessen, Tonali war die eine Figur, Identifikationsfigur, die über den Sommer weg ist. Es sind auch noch weg Paolo Maldini, der nicht mehr im Verein ist, und Latan Ibrahimovic, der für die Kabine enorm wichtig in den letzten Jahren war. Und ich würde mal sagen, mehr Milan DNA in einem Sommer zu verlieren als Maldini, Ibrahimovic und Tonali stelle ich mir schwer vor. Und dass Piolli das so gut schon ins Laufen gebracht hat, finde ich beeindruckend. Muss man wirklich sagen. Jetzt haben wir viel über das Mittelfeld geredet. Auch Pio Lisik, der von Chelsea kam, wunderbar eingefunden, da aufrecht. Zwei Mal schon getroffen, super Chemie mit Giroud. So ein bisschen diese alte Chelsea-Combo. Giroud und Poulisic haben da schon gute Chemie gehabt. Da geht mir das ganz auf. Ja, muss echt sagen, hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass Milan… Also ich fand sie in der Vorbereitung schon spannend. Ich habe ein, zwei Spiele von ihnen gesehen. Da dachte ich mir, okay, das schaut vielversprechend aus. Aber Vorbereitung ist das eine, Liga das andere. Und jetzt haben sie wirklich drei Spiele lang. Sie haben Torino, die physisch eben stark sind. Die haben sie mal eben so ein bisschen physisch zerschelten lassen. Das war so das erste Zeichen, dass sie wirklich diese Körperlichkeit jetzt auch mitbringen. Und kurz vor der Länderspielpause haben sie in Rom 2-1 gewonnen. Am Ende wurde es nochmal eng, weil sie in Unterzahl waren, weil Tomori mit gelb-rot vom Platz geflogen ist. Aber bis zur gelb-roten Karte, bis zum 2-0, das war so 60. Minute, war das ein Klasseunterschied. Also die haben die Roma von Mourinho dominiert. Und ja, ich muss sagen, sensationell wie Piolli, wie schneller diesen Umbruch hinbekommen hat.
Vor allem ja die Roma, wenn ich es gerade richtig sehe, 5-3-2 gegen den Ball.
Unangenehm. Mal den Leverkursen nachfragen.
Also nicht so schlecht. Hendrik, wird das auch in England wahrgenommen, dass Lofted Cheek und Pulisic da so eine gute Rolle spielen?
Das weniger, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich finde, du hast ja den Namen Tomori angesprochen. Das finde ich ganz spannend, weil ja England gerade auch darüber debattiert, wer denn in der Nationalmannschaft in Verteidigung spielen könnte. Harry Maguire hat ja jetzt gegen Schottland einen sehr unglücklichen Auftritt gehabt. Mich würde interessieren, wie du Tomori einschätzt und ob du der Meinung wärst, dass er auch für die Nationalmannschaft in England Richtung EM da in Frage kommen könnte für einen Stammplatz. Weil da wird hier so ein bisschen übersehen, was möglicherweise daran liegt, dass er nicht in der Premier League spielt.
Tomori ist spannend. Man muss vielleicht damit anfangen. In der vorletzten Saison, als Milan Meister geboren ist, da hat Tomori und Calullo eine unfassbare Rückrunde gespielt. Da war im Prinzip das, was Milan zum Meister gemacht hat, lag ganz viel auch an Tomori, der einfach diese Körperlichkeit ausgestrahlt hat, diesen Antritt und fehlerlos war, konzentriert. Also das war eine Saison, wo sich alle gedacht haben, wow, das ist oberstes Regal. Jetzt in der letzten Saison haben sich bei Tomori immer wieder so Konzentrationsfehler eingeschlichen. Also der ist logisch, der hat diese Präsenz, gar keine Frage. Aber der war immer für einen Bock gut, sage ich mal. Und da war jetzt die Frage über den Sommer, schafft er es wieder diese Konstanz reinzukriegen? Und jetzt muss man leider sagen, in Rom war schon wieder so ein klassischer Tomori-Moment. Also er war gelb vorbelastet, hatte dann schon ein, zwei Fouls, wo man sich schon gedacht hat, huiuiui Junge, ein bisschen runter vom Gas. Und dann beim dritten Foul, muss der gelb rot zeigen. Und da bin ich eben gespannt, ob Tomori diese Konstanz wieder reinkriegt. Wenn er die reinkommt, dann bin ich mir sicher, dass er eine Option auch für Southgate ist. Aber im Moment, wenn man sich die ganze letzte Saison anschaut, und jetzt den Start, klar, wir haben erst drei Spiele, ist es mir noch ein Tick zu wackelig, weil du immer das Gefühl hast, es ist der eine Stellungsfehler dabei, es ist die eine Unkonzentriertheit dabei, oder es ist eben der eine Ungestüme, Zweikampf zu viel dabei. Da muss er sich wieder stabilisieren, um Milan Stabilität zu geben und dementsprechend dann auch für England ein Kandidat zu werden.
Aber gut, Bellingham wird ja England sowieso zum Europameister.
Allein.
Deswegen. Ich weiß gar nicht, was da diskutiert mit Hendrik. Ja, aber interessant, was sich da schon wieder getan hat im Sommer, was dann auch –also ich habe ehrlich gesagt jetzt viel davon schon wieder nicht mitbekommen. Schande auf meinen Haupt. Aber dann geht es ja vielleicht dem einen oder anderen Hörer und der einen anderen Hörerin auch so. Eine Sache, die wir allerdings alle mitbekommen haben, wobei es gut ist, dass wir quasi darüber diskutiert haben. Schlecht ist aber, was passiert ist, ist der sexuelle Übergriff von Luis Rubiales beim WM-Finale der Frauen mit dieser endlosen Geschichte, mit unfassbar vielen Volten, die aber keine davon hat es Sinn ergeben. Jetzt ist immerhin Rubiales zurückgetreten mit einer wunderschönen Non-Pology. Und so ganz versteht er es immer noch nicht. Und das ist alles ganz, ganz schlimm. Nils, wir müssen dieses Thema auch hier nochmal kurz aufgreifen, weil ich weiß ja eben auch ein wichtiges ist. Wie hast du diese ganze Entwicklung wahrgenommen und wie wird da vor allem auch in Spanien jetzt noch drüber diskutiert? Weil es hat sich ja in der internationalen Berichterstattung jetzt so ein bisschen beruhigt jetzt nach dem Rücktritt.
Ja, wobei das Wort Rücktritt würde ich da gar nicht mal verwenden. Er gibt eher sein Amt auf, ohne wirklich das. Aber ja, ich habe natürlich jetzt auch die letzten Wochen teilweise fassungslos vernommen, was da alles passiert ist, wie er versucht hat, sich rauszuwinnen. Von wegen wurde er auch hochgehoben und sie hat ja gelächelt. Und es war doch –also um so ein bisschen nochmal das chronologisch vielleicht abzuarbeiten. Das Finale war ja am 20. August, haben wir alle mitbekommen. Und dann gab es ja schon direkt danach, fünf Tage später, diese außerordentliche Generalversammlung beim Verband RFE, wo dann eben Rubiales diese wirklich negativ denkwürdige Rede gehalten hat, wo er unter anderem falschen Feminismus hat, hat er genannt, oder wie sie versuchen, mich umzubringen, hat er wirklich wie im Film Wolf of Wall Street dieses No voy a dimitir, no voy a dimitir, also fünfmal oder so, ich werde nicht zurücktreten, so ins Mikrofon gebrüllt und hat dafür Applaus bekommen, stehende Ovation nach seiner Rede. Also man hat auch gemerkt, was bei ihm vielleicht schon mal schief läuft, so null einsichtig oder mal irgendwie Fehler eingestehen oder sagen, ich habe Mist gebaut, aber auch eben im Verband, wie viele dann auch applaudiert haben, da waren dann auch natürlich die Nationalmannschaftstrainer der Frauen, der Männer dabei. Und danach ging es dann ja erst richtig rum, dass dann die FIFA ihre Sperre aufgelegt hat, dass dann in Spanien diese über 80 Nationalspielerinnen oder Spielerinnen gesagt haben, wir werden erstmal nicht mehr auflaufen, solange es keine Änderungen gibt. Und später hat dann auch der Verband endlich mal ein paar Einsichten gehabt. Da gab es dann von diesen regionalen Chefs in Andalusien, Madrid, Baskenland usw., die haben dann auch klar geäußert den unverzüglichen Rücktritt gefordert. Und das ist jetzt mehr und mehr gegipfelt, dass dann auch die ersten Köpfe gerollt sind im Verband. Jorge Vilda ist nicht mehr da, der wurde dann schon entlassen am 5. September. Vorher hat sich der Interimspräsident Pedro Roja in einer aufrichtigen Entschuldigung an den Weltfußball gerichtet und war das der spanische Bild da ein nicht so gutes Bild abgegeben hat. Neue Trainerin der Frauen-Nationalmannschaft ist jetzt Monze Tomei. Es war früher eine Spielerin, die war aber auch lange schon im Verband und gehört auch zu den Personen, die dabei diese Rubiales-Rede mit applaudiert haben. Also, ja, jetzt bin ich wirklich gespannt, wie dann auch die Nationalspielerinnen alle reagieren werden, denn die haben ja jetzt nicht nur Rubiales Kopf gefordert, sondern generell Änderungen im Verband, was ja schon vor einem Jahr begonnen hat mit diesem Streik der einiger Spielerinnen da, da bin ich gespannt. Und jetzt eben dann am 10. September, wo es war dieser Nicht-Rücktritt eher so, ich kann mein Amt nicht mehr ausführen durch die FIFA-Sperre und ich werde meine Unschuld verteidigen. Ich glaube an die Wahrheit. Und so hat er dann sein Amt eben aufgegeben, weil er einfach aktuell das nicht ausführen kann. Auch seine UEFA-Vizepräsidentschaft hat er ja da aufgegeben. Und er macht das alles so ein bisschen zum Schutz des spanischen Fußballs, weil er Spanien was Großes vorhat, in dem Fall sich für die WM 2030 zu bewerben mit Portugal und Marokko. Und da hat er eben gemerkt, dass der spanische Fußball da jetzt nicht ein ganz gutes Bild abgegeben hat die letzten Wochen. Ob das dann jetzt noch reichen wird zur WM-Kandidatur, mal schauen. Es wird da jetzt bald natürlich auch Wahlen geben beim Verband, dass es dann ein neuer Präsident gesucht und gewählt wird. Und jetzt hat er auch noch, ich glaube am Freitag, dann seine erste Anhörung vor Gericht, da ja Genni Hamoso Klage oder Klage eingereicht hat. Also da wird noch ein bisschen mehr passieren und er sich bestimmt weiter rauswinden und zu seiner Version stehen, dass das irgendwie einvernehmlich war, auch wenn er da den Kopf ja offensichtlich mit beiden Händen gepackt hat und so weiter. Aber ja, das ist weiter eine unfassbare Geschichte, wie er da null einsichtig ist und in Spanien natürlich auch noch großes Thema, aber da kommt viel mehr dazu, weil es eigentlich gar nicht nur um diesen Kuss ging, sondern weil einfach Luis Rubiales schon allein während des WM-Finals durch verschiedene obszöne, vulgäre Gesten aufgefallen ist und auch davor schon eine lange Liste hatte, ob das die frühe Lopetegui-Entlassung war 2018 oder Supercopa nach Saudi-Arabien verkauft. Da ist jetzt wieder was Neues geleakt worden, dass er ja teilweise mit einem damals aktiven Spieler, in dem Fall Gérard Piquet, das auch so verschachert hat, ein paar Millionen für dich, ein paar Millionen für mich, ihm wird vorgeworfen, den Gewerkschafts-Chef ausspielen zu haben, Gelder des Verbands für private Reisen, für private Feiern genutzt haben und, und, und. Das ist eine sehr lange Liste, also der musste eigentlich längst weg. Und erst jetzt durch die FIFA-Sperre hat die FIFA mal was Gutes gemacht, auch wenn das nur für 90 Tage vorerst war. Erst dadurch konnte er jetzt zurücktreten. Also, man kann weiter eigentlich nur den Kopf schütteln, weil es ist jetzt immer noch kein –Ich hab Mist gebaut und es tut mir leid. Es ist immer noch ein –Ja, ich glaube an die Wahrheit, ich glaube an meine Ehrenhaftigkeit, an meine Unschuld und so weiter. Aber gut, er ist jetzt weg aus dem Arndt.
Aber ja, auch nur er. Also, es ist ja ein viel größeres System, in dem er steckt. Und nicht nur, weil jetzt ihm da Leute Standing Ovation gegeben haben, sondern trotz all dieser Verfehlungen. Also nennen wir eine Frau, die sich diese Dinge hätte erlauben können als leitende Funktion, die über so viele Jahre einfach noch im Amt gebliesen wäre. Das ist das Unfassbare. Und wurde denn thematisiert in Spanien. Es gab ja vereinzelt auch männliche Spieler, die sich geäußert haben, die zum Teil auch gesagt haben, ich spiele jetzt nicht in der Nationalelf, solange das Rubiales nicht wenigstens aus dem Amt ist. Aber die Männer-Nationalmannschaft hat ein Statement abgegeben vor ihren Länderspielen. Da wurde der Name Jenny Hamoso nicht mal genannt. Das fand ich ein bisschen irritierend. Und hat aber ansonsten Business as usual, haben auch Georgien, war es glaube ich, 7-0 abgeschossen. Wird das thematisiert, dass da von Seiten der männlichen Kollegen nicht dieselbe Solidarität kommt, wie von zum Beispiel Frauen aus anderen Ländern? Die sind da fast solidarischer.
Wird nicht wirklich thematisiert. Was schade ist, aber sowohl Spieler, die sich geäußert haben, das waren vielleicht zehn Stück, also von Bocha Iglesias. Der hat auch gesagt, er wird erstmal nicht Nationalmannschaft spielen. Isco war einer der ersten Hector-Bälerien. Ich glaube von Barca, Seji Roberto, Gilles Condé haben da was geteilt. Aurélien Churameni von Real Madrid, mann Status geteilt von der Moso. Ansonsten war das schon mal sehr überschaubar. Manche Klubs waren, sind da früh offensiv auch gegen vorgegangen. Also Xetafatla den Rücktritt gefordert. Ansonsten von Barca gab es so ein bisschen eine Vichy Vachy-Aussage, von wegen, er hat sich jetzt entschuldigt und jetzt unterstützen wir wieder den Präsidenten. Na ja, ansonsten war da nicht viel spezieller von der Nationalmannschaft, die ihr darum gebeten haben, von wegen, okay, wir lesen jetzt kurz diese paar Zeilen vor. Und das war nicht schön. Und jetzt möchten wir uns bitte, jetzt bitten wir darum, dass wir wieder über Sportliche reden, es geht um die EM-Qualifikation. Also auch sehr Vichy Vachy, aber war jetzt nicht das große Thema, dass dadurch dann nochmal ein Skandal entstanden ist. Weil einfach generell, ja, es gab öffentlichen Druck, aber es war mehr international als in Spanien selbst. Wie gesagt, zehn Spieler vielleicht, und vielleicht waren sechs, sieben, acht Vereine waren offensiv deutlich dagegen vorgegangen. Ansonsten war dieser Druck in Spanien nicht aus diesem wichtigen Kreis von der Nationalmannschaft so hoch, wie es vielleicht hätte sein müssen. Allein deswegen hat sich das jetzt drei Wochen gezogen, dass er erst durch die FIFA-Sperre, dass er da jetzt zu diesem Schlussgezug gekommen ist. Er muss sein Amt aufgeben. Also auch das hätte mehr sein können vielleicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie seht ihr anderen. Bin ich dazu moralisch überlegen, als Nicht-Beteiligter, dass ich da mehr fordere? Oder Christian, wie hast du jetzt diesen Verlauf der ganzen –Debatte kann man es ja nicht nennen –aber eben wie das begleitet wurde, wahrgenommen?
Ich muss sagen, ich finde es unsäglich. Also das sind ja so viele Faktoren, die da mit reinkommen. Nils hat jetzt ja schon viele erläutert. Was ich auch ganz schlimm finde, ist, dass seit diese Nummer passiert ist, der Titel der spanischen Frauen –ich meine, die sind Weltmeisterinnen geworden –und darüber wurde im Prinzip mehr oder weniger kein Wort mehr verloren, weil dieser Mann sozusagen sich da die Bühne dann genommen hat. Das ist jetzt nur ein Randespekt, ist mir schon klar. Aber ich finde gerade für einen Frauenfußballer, das betrifft ja auch andere Sportarten, die jetzt nicht unbedingt die große mediale Aufmerksamkeit haben. Jetzt hast du da diesen einen wirklich sportlich so großartigen Erfolg und dann wird dir das durch sowas auch noch genommen, quasi kaputt gemacht. Wie gesagt, es ist ein Nebeneffekt, aber es ist einer von so vielen Punkten, wo ich mir denke, dass es das heute noch gibt. Aber ja, anscheinend gibt es das alles heute noch.
Mich erschüttert vor allem diese absolute Uneinsichtigkeit von Rubiales. Nils, was du alles aufgezählt hast mit falscher Feminismus und so weiter, dass es da überhaupt keine Sensibilität für das Thema gibt, was ja auch wirklich zeigt, dass er der falsche Mann ist an der Spitze eines solchen Verbandes. Und dass er dann sein Abschiedsinterview bei Piers Morgan gibt, an diesem britischen Obershowie-Moderator, passt dann ja auch ins Bild.
Stimmt, die Worte hatte ich ja noch vergessen. Es lohnt sich schon bei so etwas, finde ich, genau hinzugucken und sich das einfach nur zu merken. Also zum Beispiel, die war jetzt nicht Ballon d'Or, sondern was war es? Europas Fußballer des Jahres, die ausgezeichnet wurden? Nee, was war die? Mich interessieren immer diese ganzen Preise nicht. Aber ich habe mitbekommen, da Serena Wichmann wurde ausgezeichnet, hat sich dazu geäußert, Olga Komuna wurde ausgezeichnet, hat sich dazu geäußert, Erling Haaland hat gesagt, es war immer mein größter Traum, hier zu stehen. Vielen Dank an meine Eltern. Ich will das nicht zu groß machen, aber einfach nur bemerken. Oder auch zum Beispiel, was hat denn der DFB gemacht? Also die DFB, die Nationalspielerinnen haben über ihre privaten Kanäle ein Statement des Mannschaftsrats geteilt. Ich habe das nicht auf einem DFB-Kanal gesehen, zumindest nicht initial. Bernd Neuendorf hat gesagt, ich hätte das nicht gemacht. Das war für den DFB auch auf Nachfrage von Mara Pfeiffer eine ausreichende Stellungnahme. Mehr wollten sie dazu nicht ergänzen. Die unsäglichen Kommentare, die wir da von Lothar Matthäus und Johannes Bekerner usw. gehört haben und Karl-Heinz Rummenigge natürlich –of all men –kommen ja noch dazu. Aber es war schon auch hier in Deutschland relativ still, das muss man wirklich sagen. Wie gesagt, es geht auch nicht darum, dass wir reflexhaft fordern müssen. Jeder muss sich immer mit allem solidarisieren. Aber man sollte schon hingucken, wie sich auch der eigene Verband verhalten hat und das dann einfach im Hinterkopf bei zukünftigen Entscheidungen haben.
Wobei man ja in der Vergangenheit auch schon gesehen hat, GfB und politische Themen sind oftmals ein bisschen schwierig. In England war es natürlich ein großes Thema, auch weil England ja Finalgegner war, aber auch grundsätzlich, weil es mittlerweile eine hohe Awareness gibt. Die Lionesses, das Nationalkanal, hat eine Mitteilung ausgegeben. Ich weiß nicht, ob das über den Verbandskanal war oder nur dann über die privaten Kanäle. Nein, das kam über den Verbandskanal. Also die haben sich auf jeden Fall geäußert und auch recht klar, wie ich fand, was ich gut fand. Und das sind auch verschiedene Aussagen, zuletzt von Georges Stenweger nochmal, dass ich es gut und überfällig finde, dass er zurückgetreten ist. Also das war hier schon auch ein extrem großes Thema. Und wie ihr aber auch schon gesagt habt, überschattet natürlich total den Fakt, dass Spanien zum ersten Mal Weltmeister geworden ist.
Absolut. Und es gibt noch ein weiteres Thema im spanischen Frauenfußball. Es stand zur Debatte, dass die ersten Spieltage bestreikt würden, weil die Spielerinnen-Gewerkschaft eine Erhöhung des Mindestlohns gefordert hat. Da gab es jetzt eine Einigung. Man bekommt für diese Saison 21.000 Euro Mindestlohn. Also jede Spielerin bekommt mindestens diesen Betrag pro Jahr. Jeder kann mal kurz in sich gehen, wie ihr diese Summe findet. Das ist weniger als das, was die Schiedsrichterinnen im letzten Jahr für sich erstreikt haben. Also dazu konnte sich der Liga-Verband nicht durchringen. Aber immerhin gibt es eine Einigung. Die Saison wird stattfinden und wie man das bewertet. Das ist dann etwas sehr Subjektives. Aber die Liga F, sie wird losgehen, so wie geplant. Das ist jetzt noch etwas, was sich erst in den letzten Stunden so ergeben hat. Dann kommen wir zurück zum Sportlichen. Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, vielleicht Hendrik, weil du sowieso gerade so schön am Reden warst. Wir haben jetzt über einen ehemaligen Bundesligaspieler oder einige ehemalige Bundesligaspieler gesprochen, die bei Liverpool für einiges aufsehen sorgen. Jetzt haben wir noch einen, der hat schon vor längerer Zeit in der Bundesliga gespielt, Jadon Sancho. Die Älteren werden sich erinnern. Was ist denn zu ihm zu sagen und zu Manchester United und deren Saisonstart?
Genau, Jadon Sancho bei Manchester United. Seit zwei Jahren da. Damals war er auch ein bisschen der Königstransfer, dass Manchester United den verlorenen Sohn aus der Bundesliga zurückholt. Seitdem aber eine einzige Enttäuschung, also er hat sich nicht durchsetzen können, ist eigentlich unter Keim der drei Trainer, die er seitdem hatte, also Solskjaer, Rangnick und jetzt Erik Ten Hag, eben kein Stammspieler geworden. Und jetzt ganz aktuell kam dazu, dass beim letzten Spiel vor der Länderspielpause gegen Arsenal, dass Manchester United 1-3 verloren hat, Sancho nicht mal im Kader stand, also nicht nur auf der Bank saß, sondern gar nicht im Kader stand. Ten Hag wurde dann hinterher gefragt, was ist los, wo war Sancho? Normalerweise moderiert man das als Trainer dann diplomatisch ab und sagt halt irgendwas, aber er hat dann explizit gesagt, die Leistungen im Training von Sancho und überhaupt bei Man United muss man nun mal ein gewisses Level erreichen, um in den Kader zu kommen. Das hat Sancho wohl ganz offensichtlich als Affront verstanden und hat sich dann selbst geäußert bei X, Twitter für die Älteren.
Der Piers Morgan unter den sozialen Netzwerken.
Ach genau, hat dann da geschrieben, hat Ten Ha quasi vorgeworfen, die Unwahrheit zu sagen, warum er endlich im Kader stand, dass er nur zum Sündenbock gemacht werden sollte. Wobei auch nicht ganz klar war, zum Sündenbock für was. Weil bei den ersten drei Saisonspielen davor Sancho auch jeweils auf Kurseinsätze gekommen war. Aber jedenfalls gibt es jetzt dazu, dass Sancho sich seit zwei Jahren bei Man United nicht wirklich durchsetzen kann. Jetzt auch noch dieses öffentliche Zerwürfnis mit dem Trainer. Viele Leute hier in England sagen jetzt schon, dass das war es für Sancho. Das war der Tropfen, der das fast überlaufen bringt. Der hat keine Zukunft für Man United. Es wurde auch darüber debattiert, ihn möglicherweise noch zu verkaufen vor Ende des Transfer-Fans in Saudi-Arabien. Das war ein bisschen länger geöffnet. Dazu kam es nicht, weil Sancho wohl offenbar auch nicht interessiert war in dem Wechsel. Jetzt muss man mal schauen, wie es weitergeht mit Sancho. Ob er noch eine Chance bei Man United bekommt oder ob es das tatsächlich war. Das deutet gerade viel darauf hin, dass er noch mal eine Chance bekommt. Er hat sich jetzt nach der Länderspielpause, wo er nicht im Einsatz war, weil er jetzt auch seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr in der Nationalmannschaft gespielt hat, zurückgemeldet zum Training. Es gab wohl eine Aussprache mit Herrn Haag, wobei darüber nicht viel bekannt geworden ist. Er hat diesen Post bei X wieder runtergenommen, was man ja so ein bisschen als Friedensangebot an Herrn Haag oder zumindest als Indiz deuten kann, dass er versucht, diesen Streit beizulegen. Man United ist ja grundsätzlich ein bisschen aus den letzten Jahren. Es geht in den seltsamen Fällen nur um Fußball, sondern immer auch um ganz viel anderes. Nachdem man ja schon die Probleme mit Mason Greenwood hatte, den man jetzt nicht mehr in die Mannschaft integriert hat, nach den Vorwürfen gegen ihn, gibt es jetzt Vorwürfe gegen Anthony, Vorwürfe von häuslicher Gewalt gegen Anthony, Rechtsaußen aus Brasilien, die er bestreitet. Und da hat Man United jetzt erstmal gesagt, der wird erstmal beurlaubt, also nicht suspendiert, sondern er ist beurlaubt auf ungefasste Zeit. Das heißt, Man United sucht jetzt auch einen Rechtsaußen. Und das wäre natürlich die Chance für Sancho, sich da zu beweisen. Genau, und da muss man jetzt mal schauen, wie das weitergeht. Insgesamt natürlich eine traurige Geschichte, wenn man sieht, was Sancho in der Bundesliga geleistet hat, bei Borussia Dortmund und auch, mit welchen Fanfaren er wirklich hier willkommen wurde, vor zwei Jahren in England, dass dann so jemand komplett zur Randerscheinung wird. Und es gibt dann auch so ein bisschen die Debatten, die ihn in seiner Dortmunder Zeit schon begleitet haben, über Unpünktlichkeit und Disziplinlosigkeit. Das ist auch so ein bisschen im Gespräch hier. Er hatte im Winter dann sogar mal drei Wochen, also während der WM, auch drei Wochen Pause bekommen, hat in den Niederlanden trainiert mit Trainern, die den Ten Hag ihm wohl zur Verfügung gestellt hat. Ten Hag sagte hinterher, das hat auch mit mentalen Angelegenheiten zu tun. Was dann die Sancho-Seite wohl gar nicht so toll fand, dass Ten Hag das ausgeplaudert hat. Also da gibt es auch viel bei Sancho, was so ein bisschen im Unklaren liegt und was es da auch schwer macht, ein abschließendes Urteil zu fällen. Aber Fakt ist erstmal, dass dieser Wechsel bislang halt überhaupt nicht funktioniert, hat für keine Seite. Und dass Sancho jetzt möglicherweise bei Man United so ein bisschen die letzte Chance hat, sich noch zu beweisen.
Das ist schon eine erstaunliche Entwicklung. Dann hat der Verkauf von United auch nicht geklappt. Alles zu Mason Greenwood und Anthony könnt ihr euch googeln, liebe Leute. Und ich verweise vielleicht auf das Tribüngespräch. Häusliche Gewalt im Profifußball an der Stelle. Ich werde es auch nochmal verlinken. Der Saisonstart war ja auch durchwachsen. 1 zu 0 gegen die Wolves, 0 zu 2 bei Tottenham, 1 zu 3 bei Arsenal und zwischendurch noch ein 3 zu 2 gegen dezimiertes Nottingham. Ich habe auch gelesen, Hendrik, dass Ten Hag durchaus auch umstritten ist. Und dass so manche seiner Äußerungen auch zu Sancho wie eine Vorwärtsverteidigung interpretiert wurden. Zumindest habe ich bei The Athletic mal so entsprechende Artikel quer gelesen. Ist es denn wirklich schon so kritisch mit United?
Naja, das Grundproblem bei United ist ja seit zehn Jahren, seitdem Zwerg und Ferguson weg, dass dieser Verein versucht, sich neu zu erfinden und es nie so richtig hinbekommt. Und jetzt mit Ten Hake ist jetzt die zweite Saison da, die erste lief erstaunlich gut. Und jetzt erwarten die Leute natürlich, dass es den nächsten Entwicklungsschritt gibt. Der ist aber schwierig zu machen in der Premier League, wo du solange Manchester City mit Pep Guardiola mitspielst, wo du wahrscheinlich nicht Meister werden kannst. Von daher ist da so ein bisschen die Ceiling begrenzt. Nichtsdestotrotz ist der Saisonschaft von United tatsächlich aber extrem durchwachsen. Also zwei Niederlagen, du hast es angesprochen. Die beiden Spiele, die sie gewonnen haben, waren auch alles andere als überzeugend. Gegen Wolves hätten sie verlieren müssen. Gegen Nottingham lagen sie nach, ich glaube nicht mal zehn Minuten, schon 2-0 hinten. Also das ist alles extrem unsouverän. Du hast diese Extremstörgeräusche um den Verein. Also Greenwood Anthony Sancho, der Verkauf, der nach wie vor sich hinzieht, wo nicht klar ist, ob dieser Verkauf stattfindet oder nicht. Und Ten Hag hat zuletzt auch sehr unsouverän gewirkt. Da ist dieses Sancho-Aussagen so ein Beispiel für, dass er ein Thema aufmacht, was er glaube ich nicht aufmachen muss. Und das wird spannend zu beachten. Jetzt geht ja auch die Champions League los, nächste Woche gegen den FC Bayern. Und Man United ist insgesamt immer ein riesen Thema. Es ist immer wahnsinnig viel los und in der letzten Saison saß es natürlich so aus, als würden sie so ein bisschen die Kurve bekommen. Und das ist jetzt aber zum Start dieser Saison schon wieder der gegenteilige Effekt zu besichtigen. Gibt es noch eine Verletzungskrise? Also wichtige Spieler sind verletzt. Mason Mount, der jetzt von Chelsea kam, ist verletzt. Rasmus Höll und der neue Stürmer, der für viel Geld kam, von dem man noch nicht so richtig weiß, ob der für United überhaupt taugt, hat jetzt zum ersten Mal gerade gespielt. Also da ist schon auch noch Potenzial. Da sind viele Sachen, die sich finden müssen. André Nala, neuer Torwart mit einem komplett anderen Stil, als hinterher gepflegt hat. Es ist auch klar, dass das so ein bisschen Wachstumsschmerzen verursacht. Aber bei United hast du halt nie Zeit. Und deswegen ist Ten Hag da auch extrem unter Druck. Und da bin ich gespannt, wie das weitergeht.
Ten Hag, richtig geiler Bundestrainer. Sorry, ich kann anscheinend nur noch im Bundestrainer denken. Aber jetzt DFB ein bisschen warten. Und dann sollen die Bayern gegen die gewinnen der Champions League. Und dann –nee. Vielleicht –ich bin noch zu sehr geprägt von unserer DFB-Sendung, die ich gestern Morgen aufgenommen habe an dieser Stelle. Wir wollen noch mal nach Italien gucken. Und jetzt wollen wir über Inter sprechen. Ich hatte es ja schon angekündigt. Auch drei Spiele, drei Siege, perfekter Start. Und auch kein Gegentor, wenn ich das gerade richtig sehe. Ja, absolut. 8 zu 0 ist die Torbilanz. Also läuft alles super bei Inter?
Inter ist beeindruckend aus mehreren Gründen. Da müssen wir vielleicht auch kurz die Klammer nochmal aufmachen. Da hat sich sehr viel personell im Sommer getan. Ich sage mal Onana, Skriniya, Prosovic, Lukaku, Dzeko. Das sind ungefähr fünf Stammspieler. Fünf sehr wichtige Figuren, nicht nur sportlich, auch dabei sind sie in der Kabine. Alle weg. Es kam ein gewisser Umbruch. Aber das Entscheidende, was Inter geschafft hat, wenn man uns an den Junioren erinnert, da gab es dieses Champions League-Finale, wo mehr oder weniger von außen alle gedacht haben, dass Inter da hinfährt und vielleicht gar nicht mitzählen kann. Wie oft sie das Ding aus dem eigenen Tor rausholen und was entstand, war ein Spiel, das unfassbar eng war, das City gewonnen hat, aber Inter hat genau das daraus gezogen, was man sich, glaube ich, als Klub von so was wünscht. Also Inter hat verstanden, dass den Champions League Run, den sie letztes Jahr hatten, dass da sehr, sehr viel Gutes dabei ist, auf das sie aufbauen können. Und das finde ich das Beeindruckendste, dass sie diese Selbsterkenntnis, also sie strahlen wahnsinnig viel Selbstvertrauen aus, sie strahlen wahnsinnig viel Vertrauen in ihre Fähigkeiten aus, ohne aber arrogant oder überheblich zu sein. Und das war zum Beispiel vergangenen Saison, manchmal in der Liga so ein Thema. Bastoni hat das wunderbar im Sommer beschrieben, hat gemeint, manchmal waren wir in der Liga letztes Jahr ein bisschen mental oberflächlich. Und hier haben alle Inter-Spieler im Sommer gesagt, das passiert uns nicht mehr. Wir wissen jetzt, was wir können und das wollen wir von Anfang an zeigen. Und die ersten Spiele, auch da, klar, es sind drei Spiele, brauchen wir jetzt noch nicht das riesen Ding draus machen, aber die Art und Weise, wie Inter aufgetreten ist, die war beeindruckend. Weil du in jedem Spiel das Gefühl hattest, okay, die haben all dieses Positive aus diesem, wenn auch verloren, Champions League-Finale mitgenommen. Die Sicherheit in Sagi, noch mal enger, glaube ich, mit der Mannschaft geworden. Die haben sich alle ganz klipp und klar gesagt, dieses Jahr sind wir dran, was jetzt zumindest die Liga betrifft. Sie haben ganz klar das Ziel ausgegeben. In Italien ist die Rede von La Seconda Stella, also der zweite Stern, muss man wissen. In Italien gibt es alle zehn Meisterschaften, einen Stern auf dem Trikot. Und sowohl Inter als auch Milan stehen bei 19. Das ist eine sehr besondere Konstellation. Und bei Inter hast du von allen Seiten gehört, dieses Jahr holen wir uns den zweiten Stern. Und genau das zeigen sie auf dem Feld. Laut Taro Martinez ist in einer unfassbaren Verfassung, hat fünfmal schon geknipst. Kapitän, jetzt offiziell auch, weil Handanovic ja nicht mehr da ist, geht wirklich voran. Nicht nur die Tore, auch strahlt eben genau dieses Selbstvertrauen aus. Turam funktioniert schon gut, war spannend, war eben die Frage, weil eben gerade im Sturm habe ich ja gesagt, wenn du Lukaku und Cechu verlierst, dann verlierst du erstmal viel individuelle Klasse. Da kamen jetzt eben Turam-Ablöße frei. Und was ich sehr positiv an Turam finde, er hat jetzt alle drei Liga-Spiele mit Lautaro angefangen. Sie probieren, so eine gewisse Chemie zu entwickeln. Und Turam spielt extrem für Lautaro. Also nicht nur mannschaftsdienlich, sondern auch Lautarodienlich würde ich es mal nennen. Und das geht momentan wunderbar auf, weil er für ihn Räume reißt, weil er viel unterwegs ist. Also da scheint schon eine gewisse Chemie da zu sein. Pastoni habe ich vorhin genannt. Für mich macht der jetzt den nächsten Schritt, war für mich auch schon letzte Saison fast schon oberstes Regal, was der ausstrahlt in diesen ersten Spielen, mit welch breiter Brust, wie der auch spielerisch vorne mit reingeht. Vielleicht erinnern sich noch ein paar bei Inter. Es ist zwar dieses 3-5-2, aber da kommt schon auch viel von den Innenverteidigern, gerade von Pastoni, der mit dem Marco da auf der linken Seite ein wunderbares Duo bildet. Also Inter hat unfassbar viele positive Sachen aus dieser letzten Saison mitgenommen. Dumfries zum Beispiel, den man jetzt auch in der Nationalmannschaft gesehen hat. Ich glaube, er hat jetzt allein vier Torvorlagen in den letzten zwei Nationalmannschaftsspielen geliefert. Der ist auch in Shape. Also man kann viele rausheben, aber das zeigt ja auch, dass es eigentlich die Mannschaft ist. Und einen muss ich vielleicht noch nennen, Celanolu, muss man wirklich sagen, Brosović ist ja nicht mehr da. Und Celanolu hat ja im Prinzip auch letzte Saison schon diese Sexerrolle übernommen. Und dadurch, dass sie Brosović jetzt haben gehen lassen nach Saudi-Arabien, ist auch ganz klar, Celanolu ist der neue Boss da auf der Sex. Und strahlt das auch genau aus. Er hat auch immer auf den Interviews schon vermutet und gesagt, das ist eigentlich seine Lieblingsposition. Er sieht sich auch da. Und das zeigt im Moment defensiv noch mal verlässlicher geworden. Also Inter ist wirklich im Moment, du hast es angesprochen, auch noch kein Gegentor, aber nicht, weil sie defensiv spielen, sondern da ist viel Spielfreude dabei. Sie haben viele Optionen. Es geht über außen, es geht durchs Zentrum, Mkhitaryan, Barela. Also Inter macht große, große Freude. Und anscheinend ist es in Sargent der Mannschaft in diesem über den Sommer gelungen, so diesen Pakt, den sie sich, glaube ich, den haben sie sich geschworen. Und im Moment wird er auch auf dem Feld sehr, sehr deutlich erkennbar.
Das klingt sehr gut, genauso gut wie die Warnmeldung, die gerade reinkam, trotz lautlosem Handy. Schön, dass der Alarmtag dieses Mal zumindest bei mir geklappt hat. Ausgerechnet, als du über Cialanullo als Sexer gesprochen hast. Ich hab eigentlich nur eine Frage. Was heißt Holding Six auf Italienisch?
Hat's nicht in den Sommer, hat's nicht in den großen Sprachscherz gebracht.
Ich dachte, das wäre die wichtigste Frage.
Aber Cialanullo wäre es bei Inter. Wobei auch mehr als eine Holding Six. Weil es Inter eben auch diese… Das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen, da sind viele Spiele da, die Automatismus sind da. Und Cialanullo wird auch immer wieder in Positionen gebracht, dass er im letzten Drittel auch seine Weitschussgefahr auspacken kann, weil er auch mit Gitarren gut absichert. Also das Konstrukt von Inter, an dem sich Herr City fast schon im Finale die Zähne ausgebissen hat, diese so gut abgestimmte Fünferkette, das ist immer noch da. Aber im Moment strahlen sie auch so eine spielerische Freude aus, dass es wirklich sowohl was das Defensive betrifft, als auch das Offensive wirklich ein sehr, sehr gutes Paket ist.
Mann, da ist in allen Ligen schon sehr viel los. Ich gebe es ja zu, dass wir zu spät angefangen haben mit der Ligatur. Aber lieber Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr wisst ja auch, warum. Es ist ja kein böser Wille. Wir wollen abschließend noch eine neue Kategorie mal ausprobieren. Und dann sagt ihr Hörerinnen und Hörer uns einfach, wie ihr das findet. Und wir werden auch intern nochmal in die Revision gehen. Und zwar bei der Bundesligasendung, nenne ich Spieltags-Awards. Hier sind jetzt natürlich irgendwie Wochen-Awards, so zwei wöchentliche Awards, die jeder von euch vergeben kann. Und zwar in drei Kategorien. Euer persönlicher MVP der aktuellen Phase, euer persönlicher Unsung Hero. Und falls es Ihnen gibt, einen Moment, der euch einfach in Sinn kommt, wenn ihr an die letzten Wochen in eurer Liga denkt. Und Nils darf gerne mal anfangen. MVP, Unsung Hero, Moment, die Bühne ist deine.
MVP ist natürlich erstmal offensichtlich und auch jetzt ein langweiliger Call, dass man da Jude Bellingham erwähnen muss, der auch gleich zum Spieler des Monats September, August gewählt wurde von La Liga. Aber auf jeden Fall dann eben als Unsung Heroes direkt hinterher. Einerseits Take Kubo, spielt auch einen richtig guten Saisonstart bei Real Sociedad, auch mit Japan, wie wir alle gesehen haben. Aber auf jeden Fall ungesungen ist Isco, der jetzt nochmal nach acht Monaten Vereinslosigkeit richtig aufgeblüht ist. Da passt wirklich Betis gut, das ist so eine Kickermannschaft, wo er ein bisschen dribbeln kann. Der denkt nur noch vertikal, nur noch Richtung Tor. Auch wenn seine Statistiken ein Tor bisher erst noch sehr überschaubar sind. Aber der hat jetzt, glaube ich, auch wohl in allen vier Spielen, die er gemacht hat, zum Spieler des Spiels ausgezeigt. Obwohl Betis auch mal verloren hat und so weiter. Also Isco da richtig gut bei Betis gestartet. Deswegen ist der so ein bisschen unsung. Moment der Woche tue ich mich schwer, weil irgendwie la Liga eher negativ Schlagzeilen statt. Ob das Mason Greenwood ist oder Robiales hier. Aber vielleicht, dass Sergio Ramos sehr emotional, sehr schön empfangen wurde in Sevilla. Aber das ist jetzt nix skurriles. Aber Ramos ist zurück und hat sich gegen das berühmte Geld aus. Ihr wisst schon, wo entschieden von dem her. Das vielleicht in einem Moment der letzten zwei Wochen, was auch immer.
Ich mag die Kategorie jetzt schon. Aber was ich genauso mochte, mein persönlicher Moment der Woche, Hendrik, war, als sich mehrere Premier League Trainer, unter anderem auch Jürgen Klopp, darüber beschwert haben, dass Saudi-Arabe mit seinem Geld jetzt ja alles kaputtkaufen würde, dass man da ja nicht mithalten könnte. Da dachte ich mir nur, oh, the irony.
Ja, vielleicht sollte sich die Premier League auch für Investoren öffnen.
Oh, das kommt jetzt in der Bundesliga wieder. Jetzt sollen es 700 Mille sein für 7 Prozent. Aber das werde ich in einem Tribüngespräch, denke ich, bald mal.
Aki macht ernst.
Und es sind jetzt strategische Partner. Sie wollen nicht mehr Investor sagen. Das ist ihnen ganz wichtig. Aber gut, das ist ein anderes Thema für eine andere Zeit. Hendrik, wer sind deine Mittags-Awards-Träger?
Ja, als MVP ganz klar Ansh Postekoglu, Trainer der Spurs, neuer Trainer der Spurs, wo er nach dem Harry Kane-Weggang und der nicht so berauschenden letzten Saison nicht so ganz klar war, wie geht das jetzt weiter. Richtig gute Saison starten, total erfrischender Fußball, die die unter Postekoglu spielen, sehr offensiv ausgerichtet, sehr schön anzusehen im Vergleich zu dem doch sehr trüben Mourinho und konnte Fußball davor, dazu auch ein echt guter Typ, der es schafft, die Fans mitzunehmen, hat so ein bisschen frühe Jürgen Klopp-Vibes bei Liverpool.
Wer will, kriegt auch ein geiler Bundestrainer, aber ich sag's dir.
Also das ist total erfrischend zu sehen. Und wie gesagt, gerade nach dem, was bei Spurs im Sommer und mit dem Kane-Weggang passiert ist, war das nicht abzusehen, dass sie direkt so gut die Kurve kriegen. Von daher Postekoglu, ganz klar MVP. Unsung Hero, David Moyes, Trainer bei West Ham, galt vor der Saison als einer der Kandidaten auf die erste Trainer-Entlassung. Zumal auch Declan Rice, wichtigster West-Hamm-Spieler im Sommer, den Verein verlassen hat zu Arsenal. Und David Moyes schafft es aber auch, diesen Verein wieder neu zu erfinden. Wir haben jetzt auch einen richtig guten Saisonstart gehabt, haben unter anderem Chelsea schon geschlagen, haben Brighton geschlagen, die sehr hoch eingeschätzt werden, gute Transfers getätigt. Vor allem James Wood Prowse, der aus Southampton kam, ist richtig gut eingeschlagen. Von daher David Moyes, der Unsung Hero. Ich hab einen momenten skurrilen Moment vom ersten Spieltag aus dem Spiel Crystal Palace gegen Bournemouth, was glaube ich bei Crystal Palace an der Seitenlinie steht, Roy Hodgson, ältester Trainer der Premier League-Geschichte. Und es gab eine Szene, wie ein gegnerischer Spieler Max Low an der Seitenlinie in ihn reinrauscht und beide fast zu Boden gehen. Und Hodgson in seinem stolzen Alter von 76 Jahren aber sehr energisch aufspringt und es fast aussieht, als würde eine Art Kneipenschlägerei mit dem 50 Jahre jüngeren Gegenspieler da anfangen. Und der Gegenspieler hat sich hinterher auch geäußert und meint, es tut ihm total leid, dass er da so aggressiv gegen diesen alten Herrn vorgegangen ist. Also das ist eine sehr schöne Szene und zeigt auf jeden Fall, dass Roy Hodgson auch im hohen Alter noch voll dabei ist.
Sehr gut.
Ja, ähnlich wie bei Nils, bleibe ich auch beim MVP bei Lautaro hängen. Wie gesagt, nicht nur die Tore, auch die Art und Weise, wie er die Mannschaft führt, ist jetzt der echte Kapitän, strahlt all das aus, was Inter ausmacht. Eine Zahl noch vielleicht dazu. Im Kalenderjahr 2023 hat in den grossen Ligen kein Spieler öfter getroffen als Lautaro. Also kein Haaland, kein Mbappé. Das zeigt, dass seine Tore ja sehr wichtig sind, aber auch die Art und Weise, wie er die Mannschaft mittlerweile führt. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Lautaro bei Inter jedes Jahr wirklich bis jetzt was draufgebackt hat. Er ist auf einem sehr guten Weg. Ansanghero bin ich bei Roberto Daversa und Lecce. Zu Lecce muss man kurz sagen, waren letztes Jahr Aufsteiger, sind relativ souverän dringeblieben, haben einen schönen Ball gespielt, haben aber über den Sommer wahnsinnig viel an Qualität verloren. Zum einen der Trainer war weg, Baroni, der im Aufstiegs-Trainer ein ansehnliches 4-3 hat spielen lassen. Und dann ganz, ganz wichtige Spieler wie Umtiti, ehemaliger Barca-Verteidiger, der weggegangen ist, Jülmand, der Däne Kapitän, Sechs am zentralen Mittelfeld, der nach Portugal verkauft wurde. Rekordtransfer, glaube ich 25 Millionen, so viel Geld hat Lecce noch nie eingenommen. Ein Satz dazu, den haben sie für 170.000 Euro zwei Jahre davor aus Österreich gekauft. So kann man eben auch gut wirtschaften. Also sie haben viel Qualität verloren und sie haben einen Trainer geholt mit Roberta D'Aversa, der war das eineinhalb Jahre raus, war zuletzt bei Sampdoria nicht wirklich erfolgreich. Da waren viele Fragezeichen. Und jetzt steht Lecce nach drei Spieltagen mit sieben Punkten da, hat Lazio geschlagen, aber mehr auch als die Punkte. Sie haben einfach wieder dieses 4-3-3 erfrischend nach vorne, sind eine umfassbar junge Mannschaft, eine der jüngsten Mannschaften Europas, hatten zuletzt einen Altersschnitt von 24,5. Also da ist viel Tempo drin, da ist viel Spielfreude drin und dementsprechend ganz klar für mich sozusagen Ansang der ersten Phase. In Italien kommt man nicht darum herum, es gibt einen Aufreger der letzten Tage, und das ist Paul Bogba und seine positive Dopingprobe, seit wenigen Tagen logisch beschäftigt ist, italienischen Fußballkazetten, er wurde getestet beim ersten Spiel, er war Auswechslspieler in Udine, erhöhte der Testosteronwert, angeblich kommt er jetzt raus. Juwe war ja im Sommer auf USA Tour, da hatte er sich wohl anscheinend ein Ernährungsergänzungsmittel organisiert, beraten von einem anscheinend befreundeten US-Arzt von ihm, aber anscheinend stand er womöglich auf dem Ding sogar drauf, weil ihm die Dopingregeln zwischen USA und Europa unterschiedlich sind. Fakt ist jetzt, Juwe hat ihn erst mal, also das Gehalt ruht jetzt erst mal, jetzt geht es auch darum, es ist noch keine P-Probe da, jetzt muss das alles seinen Weg gehen, aber es schaut echt nicht gut aus und es passt so in dieses Polpock Bar, wie soll man sagen, Polpock Bar und die letzten Jahre. Hendrik weiß, wie es in England war. Bei Juwe ist es eigentlich fast noch schlimmer geworden. Also er hat die ganze Saison verletzungsbedingt verpasst, die WM verpasst. Auch schon vor dieser Aktion war er das größte Juwe-Misverständnis der letzten Jahre. Die Hoffnung war ja, mit ihm so jemanden zurückzuholen, der Juwe kennt, der auch, auch wenn klar war, dass er nicht mehr der Polpock Bar der frühen Jahre ist, aber vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit seiner Art da wieder was voranbringt. Aber das hat wirklich bis jetzt schon 0,0 funktioniert und jetzt kommt auch noch diese Nummer, echt bittere Momente für ihn. Nicht auszuschließen, wenn es sich bestätigt, dass Juwe vielleicht auch den Vertrag auflöst. Das ist womöglich im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten, wenn es sich herausstellt, dass er dafür verantwortlich war. Er kostet umfassbar viel Geld. Da gab es ja auch im Sommer schon Diskussionen oder Gerüchte, ob er vielleicht nach Saudi-Arabien geht, wo es hieß, dass Juwe vielleicht gar nicht unglücklich wäre, weil sein unfassbar hohes Gehalt nichts mit sportlicher Leistung verknüpft wird. Also für Polpock Bar wirklich, muss man sagen, die Seuchenzeit geht nahtlos weiter.
Gut, dass wir das auch noch mit drin hatten. Aber hier hat die Seuchenzeit jetzt ein Ende, denn die Ligatour ist jetzt zurück. Ich danke euch drei sehr herzlich. Nils Kern, Hendrik Buchheister, Christian Bernhard und vielleicht werden wir auch noch die Ligue 1 hören, das aber dann in einer eigenen Sendung. Euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern ganz herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Der Rasenfunk ist crowdfinanziert. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da könnt ihr uns unterstützen und sagt sehr gerne weiter, dass die Ligatour zurück ist. Jetzt mit eigenem Feed, minimal anderen Farben und eben vielen, vielen Sendungen, die jetzt in den kommenden Wochen kommen werden. Mit Awards. Ich sag's einfach. Mir hat's extrem gefallen, diese Kategorie. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, bleibt gesund.